hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar total organic carbon and
conductivity excursion root-cause
investigation for pharmaceutical water
systems I am Judy O'Rourke of lab routes
and I'll be moderating this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Beckman Coulter
develops manufactures and markets
products that simplify automate and
innovate complex biomedical testing or
than 275,000 Beckman culture systems
operate in both diagnostics and life
sciences laboratories on seven
continents for over 75 years our
products have been making a difference
in people's lives by improving the
productivity of medical professionals
and scientists supplying critical
information for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions for
research and discovery to learn more
about Beckman Coulter life sciences
please visit www.hp.com/recycle you a
box which will open when you click the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing presentation just click on the
support button found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at lower left I now present
today's speaker Tony Harrison a senior
marketing manager at Beckman Coulter
life sciences Tony is experienced in
water system total organic carbon
conductivity ozone analysis cleanroom
environmental monitoring and particle
characterization he has spent the last
15 years in applied metrology for the
pharmaceutical and healthcare
manufacturing industries Tony held the
convenor ship of the ISO working group
revising ISO one four six nine eight
- one and two for microbial control in
clean rooms he served as a UK
subject-matter expert to the ISIL
working group that issued the 2015
revised versions of the ISO one four six
four four - one and two documents for
cleanroom classification these were at
the heart of the aseptic manufacturing
chapters of European GMP and the USA
cGMP documents tony is a well known
international speaker and has provided
educational seminars around the globe on
toc liquid particle counting ozone
sanitation for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring his complete bio is
found on the labyrinth website Tony
Harrison will now begin his presentation
great thank you very much for that
introduction
hello everybody I'll start my
introduction by referencing the 21 CFR
guidance from the FDA in which they
emphasize the importance of corrective
and preventative action capper for any
deviations potentially impacting product
quality
indeed the regulatory authorities expect
manufacturers to investigate deviations
take corrective action but inflation
interventions to prevent recurrence of
the deviation that is currently assess
the effectiveness of those interventions
without adequate root-cause
investigation the success of those
interventions is questioned at best
however TOC or conductivity
contaminating events can be short-lived
transient events and this makes root
cause investigations difficult as you
can't always capture a sample of the
contaminated water to carry out your
root cause analysis in this presentation
we discussed some typical sources of
contamination in water systems and how
root cause investigations can be
supported using online TOC analyzers so
today's presentation is a short one out
of 20 minutes long and I am going to
cover the FDA water quality expectations
for the pharmaceutical industry I'm
going to touch a little bit on the topic
of my
prove you're viable and non culturable
then I'll share some experiences or
examples of causes of water system
contamination that I've seen then I'll
move on to support for the root for the
root cause investigations of these
contamination events and then at the end
I'll do a short conclusion of the talk
now let's take a look at the FDA water
quality expectations for the
pharmaceutical industry whenever we use
the terms purified water and water for
injection it implies these waters meet
the quality expectations defined by the
pharmacopoeias often people talk to me
about deionized water and other types of
water they don't have a definition that
they are whatever the end user decides
they should be but purified water water
injection is very well clearly defined
in a phallic appeal so let's just remind
ourselves about these quality
expectations from the FDA there are four
critical water quality attributes
defined in the formica peers microbial
colony forming units and these are
microbes that are capable of multiplying
and proliferating to form an infection
when incubated at room temperature and
body temperature in a rich growth media
conductivity is used to detect the
amount of in organic contamination
present in the water
generally speaking organic materials are
not as ionic reactive as inorganic
materials with the exception of course
of organic acids total organic carbon
measurements are used as an indicator of
what organic material there is present
in the water and this may act as a food
source and encourage the proliferation
of microbes and finally endotoxins
waterborne gram-negative bacteria can
carry these priority anak organic
substances in their cell walls should
these be injected to a patient they can
act on the patient's body temperature
regulator the hypothalamus and give the
patient a high temperature which could
prove fatal in critically
patience currently only conductivity and
TOC can be measured accurately online in
real time the only approved FDA tests
for colony forming units and then the
toxin or currently quality control
laboratory based tests in their report
prepared to the Keon Directorate the IDI
QM expert workshop recommended a focus
on TOC and conductivity as early
indicates a potential microbial
contamination or an increase microbial
byproducts which of course could be
under toxins water system tier V low
conductivity deviations could be
precursors to potential endotoxin or
microbial excursions and should be
investigated but these events are as I
said earlier frequently transient in
nature and by the time graph samples are
taken to help the root cause
investigation the excursion has
disappeared
making root cause investigations
difficult so let's talk about viable and
non culturable there's a lot of
discussion in the industry about the
fact that the current accepted
techniques for detecting microbial
colony forming units only recover a
small percentage of the living microbes
present in the water in order for the
microbes to flourish and captured onto
agar plates and incubated in the
accepted manner they need to be a
species that flourishes in a food rich
environment at room temperature and at
human body temperature in an oxygen-rich
atmosphere those which do not thrive
under these conditions are considered
viable but non culturable typical
species that may fall into this category
could be thermo files for example there
are species that only thrive at much
higher temperatures or species that
thrive in college atrophic environments
and they're killed when they're
introduced onto an agar plate where the
abundance of food is too much and they
die equally nerves or anaerobic species
that only thrive in an oxygen starved
environment will not the well using
traditional techniques
now one could be controversial and argue
that the species that do not recover
using traditional techniques if they
were to be injected into a patient might
not cause infection as a human blitz of
course is an oxygen-rich food rich
environment obviously as human body
temperature anyway let's take a quick
look at the differences between a war
system when microbial control is
attained by sterilizing the microbes
compared to a ward system where the
micro are sanitized to actively destroy
them heat sterilization of water systems
tends to patrol the proliferation of
biofilm and microbial contamination
microbes living in a heat sun-sized
water system are generally unable to
replicate to form a colony hence they
could be considered sterilized ozone
sanitization however actively oxidizes
any organic material in the water
including the microbes and removes life
and its source of nourishment from a
water system if used correctly and this
leads to true sanitization of the water
system ie absence of life biofilm can
build up in each prize systems and all
votes kept under control by frequent
heat sterilization its present
transformer challenge when switching an
established heat sterilized system over
to an ambient wort system manufactured
using reverse osmosis as it as is now
permitted in the 2016 version of the
water for injection chapter in the
European pharmacopoeia for those of you
want to learn more about the best
practices of ozone for water
sanitization the International Society
for pharmaceutical engineering the I SPE
have a guide available to purchase from
their website apart from the obvious
contamination from biofilm there are
some other examples I wanted to share
with you during my travels around the
world to pharmaceutical ities I've heard
of many other examples of the causes of
contamination in water systems so I
chair now a handful of these examples
with you this is of course by no means
meant to the exhaustive list but it may
help some of you in your root cause
investigations if you can learn from the
experiences of others I heard about one
root cause investigation in a bulk
active pharmaceutical ingredient small
molecule manufacturing facility which
led to the team to suspect contamination
from one of the organic solvents used in
the API manufacturing process but what
puzzled them is how did it get into the
water injection system frizzle
extrinsically inspection of the location
of the wfy storage tank there was a
production waste drain covered near to
the tank but still how did the solvent
get into the tank by examining the
pattern of TOC excursions the team was
able to determine that the excursions
closely followed the end of a production
run when the production vessels were
being cleaned down ready for the next
batch thus a unique combination of
events were happening simultaneously
there was a large demand for water for
injection from the storage tank to
complete the cleaning of the production
vessels pour out at the same time the
waste containing the salt was passing
down the drain and being a volatile
substance some of the solvent was
throwing the vapor above the drain cover
high water injection demand caused the
level of water inside the wfi tank to
drop rapidly causing air to be drawn
into the tank through the vent
which was situated right over the
production waste drain cover clearly
solvent vapor was drawn into the tank
along with the air reciting the wfi
storage tank vent away from the drain
cover provided a permanent solution
preventing recurrence of contamination
event now levels of organic material in
the source water can of course also vary
widely according to the season in autumn
high levels of lethal can increase
organic content in feed waters which can
then become a challenge to purified
water makeup treatment plants
treatment plants are designed to remove
a percentage of the incoming water
contaminants but an increase in
contamination levels in the incoming
water may result in turn in increase in
contamination levels in the purified
water system itself as more gets through
the water treatment system of although
water systems are pressurized I have
known for a siphoning of to occur when a
point of use is first opened of course
when the microbiologists are taking
samples from microbial and their salts
in testing in the laboratory from the
points of use its usual practice to
first wipe the point of use down with an
industrial alcohol IPA to prevent any
potential microbial contamination hold
the sample the grab sample bind microbes
which may be present on the outside of
the point groups however this alcohol is
itself an organic material and should
some be siphoned into the point of use
then this could lead to a TOC excursion
in the loop the chapter for water
injection in the European pharmacopoeia
changed in March of 2016 to allow for
the first time the generation of dual
efi using reverse osmosis previously
they insisted on a still but now they
allow reverse osmosis in the report
repaired for the European Directorate
the e DQ M expert workshop warned that
reverse osmosis systems may not be as
robust as stills and in fact they
recommended a focus on online TOC and
conductivity as early indicates the
potential microbial contamination or
increasing microbial byproducts which
occurred of course beyond the toxins
concerns were expressed that the
microbial builds upon feed water side of
the RO
could potentially break through the
reverse osmosis membrane and contaminate
the water system equally microbial
byproducts such as endotoxins may pass
through the RO membranes now these will
be picked up as an increasing TOC levels
and possibly also as a change in
oxidation profile of the organic
material
and what we don't want to see of course
is false toc excursions and all
pharmaceutical-grade toc analyzers use
ultraviolet light to oxidize the organic
molecule and release the carbon in the
form of carbon dioxide COC results may
be reported higher than they actually
are through sensor drift in TOC
analyzers that use two sensors to
measure total inorganic carbon and total
carbon and then calculate TOC equally
aging of the UV lamps will gradually
affect the intensity of the UV light
produced in constant flow TOC analyzers
where the sample has a fixed exposure
time to the UV light this drop offering
intent in UV intensity may lead to
underreported TOC values and these would
remain undetected until the UV lamp was
replaced the European chapter to point
to 0.44 on TOC analysis emphasizes the
importance of complete observation of
the organic contamination in order to
get an accurate TOC measurement
long-chain more complex organic
molecules may create organic acids in
the process of being oxidized down to
carbon peroxide organic acids may
contribute more strongly to the
conductivity measurement than the final
Scarpa dioxide from the completely
oxidized organic so failure to ensure
complete oxidation of the organic may
result in an incorrect here C value
being reported so we've looked at some
of the potential sources of water system
contamination and the challenges for the
subsequent root cause investigations so
now let's take a look at how online TOC
and conductivity analyzers can be used
to help support improved root cause
analysis firstly as I said we want to
avoid those false TOC results and as I
mentioned the primary method used by
most pharmaceutical grade TOC analyzers
to oxidize the organic is ultraviolet
light almost all TOC analyzers using UV
light only have a single UV lamp
they don't monitor the level of UV lamp
that those are UV light that the lamp
emits thus potentially ignoring a
reduction in UV light output that may
compromise the analyzers ability to
oxidize and accurately measure toc
typical lifetime of these UV lamps is
around 12 months and if the UV lamp
fails completely then the analyzer of
course will no longer be able to analyze
toc now the danger is that in modern
water injection systems the level of toc
can be less than 10 parts per billion
and a failed toc an analysis UV lamp may
go unnoticed and this leaves the
potential also TOC excursions in the
Wi-Fi system to pass undetected if a
failure of the UV lamp is detected by
the user they may need to trigger the
need for increased graph sample TOC
analysis by the QC laboratory until the
TOC NRS can get repaired the p80 700 TOC
analyzer from Beckman Coulter has an
automatic switching main and spam beat
standby UV light and it also monitors
the UV light output should the UV light
from the main lamp for below an
acceptable level for good TOC analysis
then the standby lamp is automatically
activated an alarm set to notify the
user as I mentioned different organic
materials may require different
oxidation times to completely turn all
of the carbon present in in organic to
carbon dioxide for accurate TOC
measurement the p80 700 monitors the
change in the conductivity measurements
as the oxidation is being carried out
and it waits until there's no more
change in order to detect that the
organic has been completely oxidized
thus ensuring accurate TOC analysis
according to the European pharmacopoeia
requirements it also had just one
measurement cell to measure both T IC
and T C so sensor drift over time will
not affect the accuracy of the
calculated TOC
discussed earlier toc excursions can be
short-lived transient events the p80 700
from Beckman Coulter can be programmed
to capture a water sample the instant
that the TOC excursion is detected so
the sample can be further analyzed at a
later time to help get to root cause now
it's important to ascertain that any
reported deviations in TOC or
conductivity levels are a real deviation
and not in fact caused by a drift in the
calibration of the analyzed and so so
the first step in any root cause
investigation probably no deviation is
to check that the TOC or conductivity
analyzer is still measuring accurately
now there are two types of calibration
calibration prelate validation and
calibration adjustment and they're very
different so for calibration validation
a search by calibration standards are
run as grab samples and the performance
of the TOC analyzers compared to the 35
values a pass of this type of
calibration is given if the reported
values from the TOC analyzer are within
an acceptable percentage of the
certified by using the standards with of
course the blanks obstructed now for
calibration adjustment certified
calibration standards are again used but
these are run through the TOC analyzer
and the TOC analyzer adjusts its
calibration slope to give a best fit
against the certified values of the
standards now although it's not mandated
it is considered best practice to carry
out the follow step following step by
step procedure when tolerating a TOC
analyzer before any plan maintenance is
carried out you should carry out an as
found calibration validation just to
make sure that the TAC analyzer has been
working within specification since the
last calibration and that nothing has
gone wrong since then then you do your
plan maintenance and carry out a
calibration adjustment and this of
course fine Tunes the calibration of the
TOC analyzer to make sure it is as
accurate as possible and it protects
against gradual drift in time of the
calibration finally having adjusted the
calibration
it's good practice to carry out in hours
left calibration validation and this
confirms that the calculation slope
adjustment made in step two has resulted
in an accurate calibration compared
traceable and certified standards our
particular importance for TOC is online
TOC analyzes the system suitability test
now this test is designed to ensure that
the TOC analyzer is capable of analyzing
equally the range of organic
contaminants that might occur in
purified water and water for injection
the TOC analyzer is challenged with two
solutions the first sucrose is used to
represent the typically relatively easy
to oxidize organics found in water
systems and the second benzoquinone is
used to regret resent those organic
materials just slightly harder to
oxidize the TOC analyzed must be able to
oxidize both solutions equally well now
this test takes on particular
significance with a concerns around
potential microbial contamination or
from microbial byproducts as the type of
organic contaminants in the water may
change with time now as I mentioned most
online TOC analyzers actually measure
conductivity oxidize the organics and
met and then measure the change in
conductivity but the weakness of saw
these TOC instruments places the
measurements felt constant cannot be
checked as recommended in the solvent
appears using a conductivity solution of
a known certified value our TOC
analyzers that use direct activity
measurements a part of it to use he
analysis such as the p80 700 from
Beckman culture can have the cell
constant checked the sample entering the
conductivity cell subsequent
subsequently goes to drink and therefore
does not compromise the water loop
itself now most the second part of the
calibration this is where most TOC
analyzers cannot comply with the USP
Inipi requirements there's a requirement
checking accuracy of the conduct
conductivity meter electronics using
an external certified resistor the p80
700 has been designed specifically
discuss requirement thus satisfying all
the compliance requirements of the USD
and ep has a conductivity analysed as
well as a toc analyzer now I mentioned
this organic materials were accede eyes
in a different way and they can use very
different oxidation profiles now are
changing the oxidation profile may
indicate a change in the water organic
chemistry which is a very useful
indicator of potential precursor of an
excursion so the European pharmacopoeia
emphasizes the need for complete
oxidation of the organic contaminant to
ensure accurate TOC analysis now if you
see in increasing TOC levels combined
with a change in the oxidation profile
this could be an indicator a change to
the organic chemistry of the water and
it should trigger an investigation
before potentially larger excursion
occurs now some TOC analyzers such as
the P 8700 provide an indication of the
oxidation curve profile during each TOC
Ana analysis so a change in the type of
profile combined with a change in the
TOC levels may come together to provide
insight into a potential degradation of
the reverse osmosis system into
integrity prompting the user to
investigate further and consider
corrective action to prevent a large
sterile contamination event and put in
place preventive measures to avoid the
recurrence of the problem in future now
as part of the root cause investigation
in order to identify if the
contamination is coming from one of the
points of use on the loop graph samples
should be taken at different points in
the loop the 8,700 allows users to
analyze up to four graph samples as time
for TOC and acidity using the onboard
auto sampler 21 CFR part 11 compliance
is ensured for these grab samples and
the results that they generate
because the results are generated in a
secure password-protected files and they
include the technicians electronic
signature so I'm coming to the end of my
presentation now I just want to give you
a summary of the challenges for cause
investigations in water systems and how
the p80 700 from Beckman Coulter can
help as I mentioned purified water and
water for injection excursion events can
be short-lived in transit in nature when
PFC analyzer the capture a sample of the
contaminated water can provide
invaluable assistance in group caused
investigations data on changes to the
oxidation profiles from materializer can
also be a useful indicator of potential
changes to the waters organic chemistry
providing an early warning of potential
deviations and sorry deterioration in
reverse osmosis membranes the ability to
analyze samples on the TOC analyzer to
support root cause investigations
including 21 CFR part 11 support for
electronic signatures using Microsoft
Active Directory is a great advantage
and a time saver at the same time
avoiding false high or low TOC results
through robust analyzer design with also
switching main and standby UV lamps can
help reduce wasted time in unneeded root
cause investigations and avoiding the no
fault found results that the regulator's
really don't like thoughtful choice of
TOC analyzer can provide much needed
support for ward system deviation root
cause investigations so thank you for
listening that concludes my talk today
for those of you who want to read more
you should have all received an
invitation on your screens to register
receive my white paper on the subject so
I'd like to thank you all for listening
and now invite any questions thank you
Tony for your presentation and yes
before we begin the question-and-answer
session I want to advise that a poll
question is appearing on your screen you
may select your answer then close the
poll question by clicking on the X in
the right corner and as you see the poll
questions do you want to register to
receive the
paper on this topic from today's speaker
thank you a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
Tony Harrison will answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is why did UV lamp intensity
affect TOC analysis yeah good question
well as I said in the presentation
most years he analyzes use the light
from the UV lamp to oxidize the organic
material in the water and release the
carbon atoms in the form of carbon
dioxide
now if the UV lamp output starts to fill
then the oxidation will become less
powerful and Pitino sea analyzers where
the water constantly focused through the
analyzer the organic will have a fixed
exposure time to the UV lamp so reduced
UV output actually may mean that not all
the organic is oxidized and this will
result in the TOC being underreported
and the p80 700 actually monitors the UV
lamp output an automatic is on the
standby UV lamp if the main UV lamp
output starts to fail why did different
organics have different oxidation
profiles yeah it's a good one
as they Bachelor bonds are broken in the
organic by the UV light the organic or
so the organic molecule begins to break
down now in short chain molecules the
carbon is quick released and turns into
carbon dioxide
however the oxidation profile of these
simple molecules to be very flat and
very simple but in more complex longer
chained organic molecules intimacy's may
be formed as the molecules broken down
to carbon dioxide
now if these intermediates are organic
acids they all contribute more strongly
to the conductivity than the final
column dioxide does and the oxidation
profile these complex molecules tend to
include an initial hump in the oxidation
profile as the intermediates trade a
higher conductivity the p80 700 reports
these curve types and whilst it can't
tell you what the organic is exactly
a change in the TOC levels combined with
a change in the reported oxidation curve
can be used as an indicator there's been
a change the organic chemistry in the
water when this could be a precursor to
a larger contamination event and prompt
preventive interventions before the
water goes out of compliance why our TOC
excursions frequently short-lived
transient events so that's what although
although we talk about TOC in terms of
parts per billion
the real units are in fact micrograms
per liter of water so it's actually
measuring the weight of the organic
carbon in the water and micrograms per
liter now frequently the most common
actually that I've seen source of
excursions into the sea it's caused by
the biofilm inside the pipe breaking
away and that's particularly common just
after a heat sanitization this adds a
certain amount of micrograms of TOC into
the water now this water circulates back
into the storage tank and of course the
storage tank can have Faust the gallons
in there so these few micrograms of TOC
is their diluted many times over by the
large amounts bought in the storage tank
when this drops down the total number of
micrograms per liter and hence the total
number of parts per billion so hence the
TOC excursion is caused by biofilm
shedding then you're often witnessed
frequent short-lived TOC excursions
particularly just after sun
sterilization heat sterilization that's
an indication that the biofilm is
picking up on the pipe but it's very
difficult to carry out ruse cause
analysis and these transient events
because it's not easy to capture a
sample of the contaminated water the p80
700 is designed so that it can capture a
sample of the contaminated water as soon
as it sees that excursion at or occur
and this gives a very strong support for
your root cause investigations I would
like to once again thank Tony Harrison
for his presentation do you have any
final comments
just again to thank everybody for
listening today and yeah if you want to
see that white paper please register
through the poll thanks again
I'd also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed after the webinar we'd also
like to thank our sponsor Beckman
Coulter life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand through April
2018 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye